what is up peeps we have ourselves
three tv maybe there's more but we got
sent
three tv spots for godzilla versus kong
official trailer comes out this sunday
so please subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our reaction for that
is up i didn't want to check out these
tv spots why
because over the course of a few years
we've only gotten two seconds at a time
and now each of these tv spots is
double that they're between five to six
seconds each let's triple that
they're gonna spoil the whole movie so
let's see what's in store
everything we've been seeing so far even
the little bits do look pretty awesome
i gotta admit man they do look great
though and then we'll also talk about
whatever we can catch here at the same
time
let's just play them all at once then
the first time around
godzilla will come for him
[Music]
cool are you coming or not
wait a minute okay we gotta run that
back wow
wow god damn i have to feel that
nipple oh my god
it's a solid nip right there whoa this
that is
okay so this bottle raises 18 seconds
was really like 15 seconds in total
yeah they keep teasing this specific
moment and i'm kind of wondering if
there's going to be two fights here but
i love that you know like
kong is looking down and then like where
is he
where's that where's that did i see
something down there is this is that my
surprise reflection oh
this must be uh her love interest the
the goofy nerdy guy who they might have
a little cute crush going on here that's
the part everyone most cares about
is millie bobby brown and this cute guy
i totally remembered that these human
characters were going to show back
up it just looks so vicious this is the
moment that stood out to me right here
though
what is he smashing i think he is
slowly coming back to me right now like
a a
year ago i remember seeing they released
a toy
where kong had a battle axe and it was
theorized that the axe because of how it
looked
might have been from spikes from the
back of godzilla and he formed it
into an axe
[Music]
and i'm savage i remember that toy being
released um
we'll flash it on screen if i'm able to
find it but i think that's what it is
holy [ __ ] he give god a battle addict
and i mean whoa thinking of it makes me
think
like 2001 you know like the apes making
tools and stuff
yes kong is as advanced and you know
masterful as he
is you know of course he can make
himself a godzilla battle axe
and then here you got kong all chained
up man that
looks so scary it looks really scary
and then he's connecting with that's
going to be his new love interesting
with the remaking king kong half of it's
going to be a remake of king kong
this is it he's going to fall in love
with his little girl it's going to be
king kong but what if it was also
bumblebee this little girl
she looks like that's not millie bobby
brown looks like a little asian girl
you can't have a kaiju movie without a
couple asian children
you know what it could be god was it was
in the mothra films they were introduced
those those twins
yeah i wanna say sho
shobjin
i so want to fill in this blank right
now and i just what they were
called i don't remember they're like
telepathic yeah the little princesses i
don't know if that's a
i don't think that's the character but
maybe it's in a mother maybe it is
though which is certainly connected
would come ask them she could have a
twin hiding somewhere here
yeah well and funny enough i mean this
does i i for fun
looked up what king kong vs godzilla was
like just because there is a 60s movie
where they do go ahead
kong one in that one yeah and uh you
know it does seem like they're at least
gonna take a few plot elements you know
kong is being brought over on some kind
of boat and then godzilla intercepts
there although it seems like you know
the motivations
yeah the sort of you know true setup is
mysterious even still what i find
fascinating about this
shot right here normally with the images
that we've been seeing is depending on
which character we're focusing on the
shading the color
will reflect their respective franchise
of the current monster verse they have
going right
yeah so normally if you're with godzilla
it would be the blue lighting kong it
would be that red lighting and
here you got kong but he's under the
blue lighting so i don't know what this
means yeah i feel like because he's in
the chains i almost feel like yeah he's
out of his element he's in the blue
light he's sort of at the
mercy of godzilla's world now and then
yeah what happens when you see kong and
godzilla in a more
orange red you know vietnam-looking sort
of color palette
i mean to me it's all about that battle
axe dude no that's the money shot
there's gotta be some stuff so maybe
maybe they've been confident with
teasing this because it isn't a
build up to this finale fight maybe this
isn't the finale fight
maybe they get into a fight early on
kong does
beat him and then they have a rematch at
the end where
where godzilla beats him yeah that's
where i'm
that's what i'm thinking is what's going
to happen that could be cool it's pretty
amazing when you slow this down how much
your mind can actually gather
information from all this stuff
they are making out of little tiny
two-second bits
because even these that are six seconds
longer are only like a little smashed
togethers of two second moments
i mean maybe this military here's
monarch i don't see any clues that
really
indicated that there's there's their m
on that is it on that tank
right oh oh right here okay there it is
oh yeah you're right yeah okay so that
is monarchy right here
still all the most beloved human
characters
and then maybe the fight back here is
um that first fight that we're seeing or
maybe they're unleashing another titan
at this moment
they could well that's the other thing
is is how many other types i know i i
really hope adam wingard sticks to that
gun of like
one of them is gonna there's gonna be a
definitive answer
however i can also see them bringing in
a slew of other monsters which i'm
afraid opens up that door for like
ah let's just team up at the end and
fight all these other guns i'm trying to
make out where he might be jumping from
because it looks like
the first fight it has to be two fights
obviously
two different times of dave right yeah i
feel like this has
because he is still in chains here he's
still collared up when he is fighting
um godzilla this has to be the first
fight i bet king kong
wins in this first fight yeah on like
the navy
naval deck ships and all that that's
what it looks like yeah and then
then here you're actually getting one
that's within the city maybe
through cinematography wise if you look
at this first fight with them
the lighting does reflect more of kong's
lighting
where here i mean yes you do got the
godzilla blast and it's nighttime so
it's
obviously going to illuminate more of
the godzilla color palette but i feel
like there could be a visual indicator
as well like absolutely this is the time
when he actually wins this is actually
his fight right here
i'm excited man it's so funny like
they're just so
slight but they are getting me really
excited
yeah i mean i feel like godzilla will
win ultimately in the end
i'm curious to know where you guys land
on this or
who you think might actually win but
damn this is exciting
yeah looking like i'm so excited for
sunday really quick let me just look
that
that that up i feel like i got the names
right yeah yeah yeah hey
that was close it's better than i did it
was close
show showbiz shobijin i mean that's not
their names
i don't know how the emphases work the
showbiz
and and then uh that's what they refer
to as and then let me
see if i could find king kong battle axe
right here there it is there that's so
cool yeah then you see here
you got the i'm on amazon right now and
you see the buy one of these
as soon as the videos this right here is
a close-up on the axe
and see how that looks kind of like it's
um godzilla's
he's going all kryptonite on it yeah
yeah exactly yeah
oh no and i feel like that could be
brutal especially if that's later on in
the movie too i feel like that could be
the big like oh god is he actually gonna
try if he can actually do some real
damage with this thing and that'll be
the sort of
underdog moment for godzilla let's do it
guys
i'm excited i'm excited guys leave your
thoughts down below and who you think
will win subscribe click that
notification bell
hit the like button if you're pumped
let's get into it people